>>> THIS STORM WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO INTENSIFY.
IF YOU WANT TO LEAVE, AS THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID, NOW IS YOUR
LAST CHANCE.
WE CANNOT SEND FIRST RESPONDERS
INTO HARM'S WAY BECAUSE YOU
DECIDED NOT TO LEAVE.
>> 155 MILE PER HOUR WINDS.
THAT IS WHAT HURRICANE IAN IS
NOW PRODUCING AS IT BEARS DOWN
ON FLORIDA'S COAST.
I'M JOHN BERMAN LIVE IN TAMPA
THIS MORNING.
BRIANNA KEILAR IS IN WASHINGTON.
THIS IS CNN'S SPECIAL LIVE
COVERAGE OF A STORM THAT IS
GETTING MORE POWERFUL BY THE
MINUTE.
THE NATIONAL HURRICANE CENTER
JUST REPORTED IT HAD A PLANE
FLYING THROUGH THE CENTER OF
THIS STORM MEASURING SUSTAINED
WINDS, SUSTAINED OF 155 MILES
PER HOUR.
THAT IS JUST 2 MILES PER HOUR
SHORT OF A CATEGORY 5 STORM AND
IT COULD STILL STRENGTHEN BEFORE
IT MAKES IMPACT OVER THE NEXT
FEW HOURS.
EXPECTED TO MAKE LANDFALL,
DIRECT LANDFALL SOUTHWEST OF
WHERE I AM -- SOUTH OF WHERE I
AM NEAR THE FORT MYERS AREA.
THE WIND SPEED JUST ONE OF THE
MAJOR CONCERNS HERE.
THE STORM SURGE, WHICH THE WIND
SPEED ONLY EXACERBATES, COULD BE
DEVASTATING.
HERE IN TAMPA COULD BE ANYWHERE
4 TO 6 FEET.
FURTHER SOUTH WHERE THE STORM IS
EXPECTED TO MAKE LANDFALL COULD
BE UP TO 12 FEET.
SO MANY THOUSANDS OF STRUCTURES
ARE IN LOW LYING AREAS ALONG THE
COAST.
SO THE WIND, THE SURGE AND THEN
THERE'S THE RAIN.
IT'S NOT RAINING THAT HARD HERE
NOW BUT IT'S BEEN POURING FOR
MOST OF THE NIGHT HERE AND IT IS
EXPECTED TO POUR FOR THE NEXT 24
TO 36 HOURS.
THEY COULD SEE ONE TO TWO FEET
OF RAIN IN THIS AREA.
JUST THINK OF WHAT THAT MIGHT
MEAN.
IT MIGHT MEAN A STORM SURGE UP
THE HILLSBORO RIVER, REPORT OF 6
FEET, AND THEN A FOOT OR TWO OF
FRESH WATER FLOODING COMING DOWN
THAT VERY SAME RIVER.
SO THIS COULD BE DAYS OF AGONY
UP AND DOWN THE COAST HERE.
MORE THAN 2.5 MILLION PEOPLE
UNDER SOME KIND OF EVACUATION
WARNING AND WE ARE BEGINNING TO
HEAR FROM OFFICIALS IN CITIES UP
AND DOWN THE COAST THAT THEIR
EMERGENCY SERVICES WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
PROBLEMS OR CALLS.
SO HOPEFULLY IF YOU'RE ON THE
COAST HERE YOU'VE ALREADY MADE
YOUR PREPARATIONS, YOU'VE
ALREADY GONE WHERE YOU NEED TO
GO.
AT THIS POINT YOU PROBABLY NEED
TO STAY WHERE YOU ARE, HUNKER
DOWN FOR THE REMAINDER OF THIS
STORM.
BRIANNA?
>> LET'S HEAD FURTHER IN TO
FLORIDA.
THE FLORIDA KEYS GETTING
BATTERED.
MAJOR FLOODING REPORTED THERE.
AT LEAST TWO POSSIBLE TORNADOES
REPORTED IN SOUTH FLORIDA
RIPPING TREES RIGHT OUT OF THE
GROUND.
YOU CAN SEE ONE RIGHT HERE.
ANOTHER DAMAGING SEVERAL PLANES
AND HANGERS AT THE NORTH PERRY
AIRPORT IN BROWARD COUNTY AS YOU
SEE IN THESE PICTURES THAT HAVE
COME TO US.
SMALL PLANES FLIPPED.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE IMAGES FROM
ON BOARD A U.S. GOVERNMENT
PLANE.
THIS IS THAT PLANE THAT FLIES
THROUGH THE EYE WALL OF THESE
MONSTER STORMS AND HERE IT IS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS ONE.
STUNNING VISUALS THAT SHOW AS
WELL THIS HURRICANE AND ALL OF
THE LIGHTNING THAT IT IS
BRINGING WITH IT AS IT SWEEPS
OVER THE GULF ON ITS PATH TO
FLORIDA.
JOHN?
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE LIVE TEAM COVERAGE UP
AND DOWN THE FLORIDA COAST.
WHEREVER WE CAN GET A SIGNAL.
AS THIS STORM BEARS DOWN.
LET'S GO FIRST ACROSS THE BAY
HERE TO BRIAN TODD WHO IS
STANDING BY IN ST. PETERSBURG.
BRIAN?
>> Reporter: RIGHT, JOHN.
YOU MENTIONED FIRST RESPONDERS
NOT BEING ABLE TO COME OUT WHEN
THE WINDS TO GET TO 40 MILES AN
HOUR.
WINDS HERE 30 MILES AN HOUR.
THE TOP GUSTS 30 MILES AN HOUR.
WE'RE NOT FAR FROM THAT POINT IN
THE COMING HOURS WHERE OFFICIALS
ARE TELLING RESIDENTS, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO STAY HERE, YOU'VE GOT
TO BE READY FOR THE FACT THAT
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET TO YOU ONCE
THE WINDS GET TO 40 MILES AN
HOUR.
WE'RE CLOSE TO THAT POINT HERE.
WE'RE STANDING HERE AT AN INLET
WHERE, AGAIN, STORM SURGE IS
GOING TO BE AN ISSUE.
THEY COULD GET 4 TO 7 FEET OF
STORM SURGE WHICH COULD PUSH
THIS WATER YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT
UP OVER HERE TO WHERE I'M
STANDING AND MOVING TO YOUR
RIGHT.
THIS IS BEACH DRIVE OVER HERE IN
ST. PETERSBURG.
THIS WHOLE AREA SUSCEPTIBLE TO
FLOODING.
THIS AREA, THIS COUNTY IN
FLORIDA, PINELLAS COUNTY HAS
HIGH NUMBERS OF PEOPLE UNDER
EVACUATION ORDERS.
442,000 PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTY
WERE UNDER MANDATORY EVACUATION
ORDERS.
MANY PEOPLE ARE HEEDING THOSE
WARNINGS.
JOHN, A BIG TEST HERE IS GOING
TO BE OF THE SEWAGE SYSTEM HERE
IN ST. PETERSBURG.
THAT HAS BEEN A HUGE ISSUE IN
RECENT YEARS BECAUSE THE SEWAGE
SYSTEM FOR YEARS WAS ANTIQUATED,
GOT BACKED UP WHEN A MAJOR STORM
HIT.
IN 2015, 2016 THEY HAD ABOUT 200
MILLION GALLONS OF SUAGE SPILL
INTO THE AQUIFERS WHEN THERE WAS
A MAJOR STORM.
JUST THIS PAST DECEMBER THEY
STARTED TO REVAMP AND RENOVATE
THAT SEWER SYSTEM.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A HUGE TEST
OF WHETHER THAT SEWER SYSTEM IN
ST. PETERSBURG IS GOING TO WORK.
THE PUBLIC WORKS ADMINISTRATOR
HERE IN ST. PETERSBURG IS
TELLING PEOPLE, CONSERVE WATER.
DON'T RUN YOUR DISHWASHERS.
DON'T RUN YOUR WASHING MACHINES.
LIMIT YOUR FLUSHING AND LIMIT
YOUR SHOWERING WHEN THIS STORM
IS AT ITS PEAK.
THAT'S GOING TO BE IN THE NEXT
TEN HOURS OR SO.
AGAIN, ST. PETERSBURG NOT ONLY
GOING TO FACE MAYBE SEVERE
FLOODING IN THESE AREAS HERE
BEHIND ME AND DOWNTOWN ST.
PETERSBURG, BUT ALSO IT'S GOING
TO BE A BIG TEST OF WHETHER THAT
SUAGE SYSTEM HERE CAN HOLD UP.
SOME ANXIOUS MOMENTS AHEAD IN
THE NEXT, I'D SAY, 10, 12 HOURS.
>> I'LL BET.
12 INCHES, MAYBE 24 INCHES OF
RAIN.
IT TAXES THE SYSTEM SO MUCH
ACROSS THE STATE.
I WANT TO GO RIGHT TO PUNTA
GORDA.
OUR RANDI KAYE IS STANDING BY
HERE.
THAT IS WHERE THE STORM MIGHT
MAKE LANDFALL.
WE GOT WORD THAT THE STORM IS
GETTING EVEN STRONGER.
155 MILE PER HOUR SUSTAINED
WINDS.
>> Reporter: YEAH, JOHN, THAT IS
CERTAINLY NOT GOOD NEWS FOR THE
FOLKS HERE CONSIDERING IT COULD
BE HEADING STRAIGHT FOR US RIGHT
HERE.
I AM JUST ON THE EDGE OF
DOWNTOWN PUNTA GORDA.
I'M STANDING ON THE DOCK HOLDING
ONTO THE POST BECAUSE THE WINDS
ARE GETTING A LITTLE STRONGER
CERTAINLY.
WE CAN FEEL THAT.
THEY'RE DEFINITELY INCREASING IN
INTENSITY.
THE RAIN MUCH HEAVIER THAN IT
WAS WHEN I SPOKE TO YOU LAST
HOUR.
WE ARE ON THE EDGE OF THE PEACE
RIVER.
THIS IS A BOAT LAUNCH ON THE
EDGE OF DOWNTOWN AND THE PEACE
RIVER FEEDS INTO CHARLOTTE
HARBOR.
SO THEY ARE EXPECTING, AS YOU
KNOW, THIS 8 TO 12 FOOT STORM
SURGE AND THIS COULD VERY WELL
OVERFLOW BECAUSE THE OCEAN WATER
IS GOING TO -- THE STORM IS
GOING TO PUSH THAT OCEAN WATER
INTO THE HARBOR.
IT WON'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO
GO.
IT'S GOING TO FLOOD INTO
DOWNTOWN PUNTA GORDA WHICH IS
RIGHT JUST -- WE COULD WALK
THERE FROM HERE.
IT'S VERY, VERY CLOSE.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STORM SURGE.
PEOPLE HERE HAVE BEEN CERTAINLY
HEEDING THE WARNINGS.
THE COUNTY HAS ABOUT 2/3 OF ITS
PEOPLE UNDER AN EVACUATION
ORDER.
126,000 PEOPLE OR SO.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CONCERNED
BECAUSE EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE
GOING TO SHUT DOWN AT
45-MILE-AN-HOUR WINDS, FIRE,
POLICE HELP.
THERE WON'T BE ANY HELP FOR
ANYONE IN THIS COMMUNITY, AS YOU
KNOW, ONCE THINGS GET EVEN WORSE
THAN THEY ARE RIGHT NOW.
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS BEFORE
BUT NOTHING LIKE A RAIN EVENT
AND A STORM SURGE EVENT LIKE
THEY ARE EXPECTING HERE.
THEY DID LIVE THROUGH HURRICANE
CHARLIE BACK IN 2004.
IT WAS A CAT 4, CAME RACING FLEW
HERE, JOHN.
AS YOU RECALL, IT WAS MOVING
VERY, VERY FAST.
25 MILES AN HOUR COMPARED TO
THIS, WHICH IS 5 MILES AN HOUR,
HURRICANE IAN.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH OF A STORM
SURGE.
IT WAS VERY MUCH A WIND EVENT.
THEY'RE VERY, VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF WATER THAT'S
GOING TO BE RUSHING INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING DOWNTOWN
AND SEVERAL OTHER AREAS.
THERE ARE BARRIER ISLANDS THAT
HAD TO EVACUATE.
THEY WERE THE FIRST TO GO, BUT
WE'VE MET PEOPLE WHO WERE
HUNKERING DOWN ON A BOAT NEARBY.
THERE ARE BOATS OUT HERE IN THE
HARBOR HERE BEHIND ME.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AS THIS
INCREASES IN STRENGTH, JOHN.
>> RANDI, STAND BY FOR A MINUTE.
I WANT TO BRING IN CHIEF
METEOROLOGIST CHAD MYERS INTO
THE WEATHER CENTER TO JOIN THE
DISCUSSION.
CHAD?
>> JOHN, AND TO RANDI WHERE YOU
ARE, I WAS ALMOST IN THE EXACT
SAME SPOT FOR CHARLIE YEARS AGO.
ALONG THIS WHAT WE CALL THE
CANAL ZONE WHERE ALL OF THESE
LITTLE HOMES ARE PLACED ONLY
THREE FEET ABOVE SEA LEVEL, THEY
HAVE A LITTLE NICE DOCK AND THEY
CAN TAKE THEIR BOAT OUT INTO THE
GULF.
THE SURGE NOW IS BETWEEN 12 AND
16.
THAT NUMBER HAS GONE UP.
THEY'RE ONLY 3 FEET ABOVE SEA
LEVEL.
IF YOU SURGE THAT MUCH, IT'S
GOING TO BE UP AGAINST THEIR
GUTTERS OR HIGHER.
ARE ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE GONE?
>> Reporter: THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE UNDERSTAND FROM THE OFFICIALS
THAT THEY EVACUATED ZONE A, THE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND THE
BARRIER ISLANDS, THEY DID SAY
THEY WERE HEEDING THOSE
WARNINGS.
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO GET INTO
THOSE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF THE
EVACUATION ORDERS, BUT FROM WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND THEY DID -- THEY
DID EVACUATE.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AS BAD AS THEY
THOUGHT.
PEOPLE MOVE TO FLORIDA, AS YOU
KNOW, CHAD AND JOHN, TO LIVE ON
THE WATER AND THEY KNOW WHAT
COMES WITH IT.
>> JOHN, THIS ISN'T MAYBE AS BAD
AS IT GETS.
THAT WOULD BE A 10, BUT THIS IS
A 9.
IT IS RIGHT THERE.
IT IS THE POWER AND WIND OF WHAT
WE HAD DOWN HERE IN 2004 WITH
CHARLIE AND THE SURGE NOW OF
KATRINA.
TWO STORMS.
WE KNOW THEY'RE ALWAYS ALL
DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW?
AND YOU'RE GOING TO GET A LOT
LESS THAN RANDI.
DO YOU HAVE A PLACE TO GO?
CAN YOU GET OUT OF THERE?
>> Reporter: YEAH.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A PARKING
GARAGE FOR US BECAUSE WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR CARS
FLOODING AND FLOATING AWAY, BUT
ALSO FOR OUR OWN SAFETY WE DO
HAVE A PARKING GARAGE TO HUNKER
DOWN IN AND SOME OTHER SAFE
AREA